[MUSIC PLAYING]
JON FAUST: Hi, and
welcome to episode 203
of the weekly Google
Cloud Platform podcast.
I am Jon Foust.
And I'm here with
my colleague, Aja.
Hey, Aja.
How's it going?
AJA HAMMERLY: Pretty good.
How are you doing, Jon?
JON FAUST: Pretty good.
The weather's turning a
little cold here in New York.
So I am currently bundled up in
a very thick sweater and a wool
cap.
AJA HAMMERLY: I have to
admit, I'm a little jealous.
It is not quite cold
enough here yet.
So what are we going to be
talking about this week, Jon?
JON FAUST: This week
we're going to be
talking to Donna Malayeri
about Cloud Run for Anthos.
Donna's very, very
passionate about Cloud Run.
And it's going to be
very interesting to hear
all the cool things that we
can do with Cloud Run, as well
as the differences between
Cloud Run for GKE Anthos.
And that's it.
Yep.
AJA HAMMERLY: Yeah.
And I think, looking
at our notes here,
that you're going to have
a question about Open
Match, which is the project
that you've been diving
into the last couple weeks.
JON FAUST: Yeah.
Our question of
the week is going
to be pretty much about
how to write a matchmaking
function in Open Match.
And that's going to be very
helpful, because we've just
improved the developer
experience for Open Match.
So we're really hoping that
people will take a deep dive
and have some fun with it.
AJA HAMMERLY: Cool.
But first, my favorite part.
Cool thing of the week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
What's your first
cool thing, Jon?
JON FAUST: AutoML
has been brought
to Kaggle, which is great.
And they've hit a milestone
at 3.5 million data scientists
using and learning about AutoML.
So if you don't
know what Kaggle is,
it's an online community for
data scientists and machine
learners.
And you get to
look at data sets.
And you can publish your own.
And it also is a
learning platform.
So if you're very
interested in learning
about any type of machine
learning concepts or anything,
and if you want to just
play with some data sets,
take a good look and
add to those numbers.
AJA HAMMERLY: That
sounds so cool.
I love Kaggle and all the
cool data sets they have,
and how they make
machine learning and data
science slightly
more approachable,
cause it's kind of terrifying
if it's not your background.
JON FAUST: Right.
AJA HAMMERLY: So I
have two cool things.
My first cool thing
of the week is,
I was dorking around this
morning, looking at blogs,
and trying to figure out
what things on my task list
had fallen off the bottom.
And I remembered,
the GCP podcast
actually has a page on
the website, Dev.TO.
The link is going to
be in the show notes.
But it's Dev.TO/GCPPodcast.
That particular website,
content aggregator,
whatever you want to call
it, has a special type
for podcast episodes.
And I had set that up.
And I had forgotten
that I had done that.
So it's there.
It's super cool.
If you prefer that
platform, you can come,
leave us comments
and such there.
JON FAUST: That's awesome.
And to wrap up my cool things
of the week, scripting and store
procedures have
finally gone beta
in BigQuery, which is kind
of awesome, because if you're
used to writing really
complex tasks in BigQuery,
with scripting you can have a
little bit more control flow
and execution flow with the
use of if statements, while
statements, and even variables.
So you can store these
scripts as procedures,
which would be kind of great.
So if you want a little bit
more control and a little bit
more ease, give that a look.
AJA HAMMERLY: Awesome.
And my last cool
thing of the week,
my second cool thing of the
week is Skaffold is now GA.
I thought that on the
Cloud Platform blog.
And Skaffold is
this awesome tool
that folks are using
to help simplify
working with Kubernetes,
because Kubernetes
has a lot of moving parts.
Help simplify containerization.
And yay.
It's GA.
I am so excited.
I don't like using
beta products.
I like using GA products.
So I'm super happy
that it's now a GA.
JON FAUST: That's awesome.
Let's go into our
interview with Donna
and see what she has to say
about Cloud Run for Anthos.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Hi, and on this
episode of the podcast,
we're joined by Donna Malayeri,
a fellow Googler who currently
works on GKE and Cloud Run.
So Donna, can you tell us
a little bit about yourself
and what you do?
DONNA MALAYERI: Yeah.
I'm the product manager
for Cloud Run for Anthos.
And I'm here to talk
about Cloud Run.
I've worked in the Serverless
space for a few years.
I worked at the
Seattle startup Pulumi,
which builds tools for deploying
modern cloud applications.
I worked on Azure functions.
I used to do a lot of stuff
in programming languages.
So I've been in the developer
tool space for a while.
JON FAUST: Awesome.
So you mentioned that you
work on Cloud Run and Anthos.
Can you tell us a
little bit about that?
DONNA MALAYERI: So Cloud Run is
a really interesting product,
because it offers
Serverless containers.
And it comes in two flavors.
There is a fully
managed version,
which is the one that's
suitable for most users.
And essentially, you
run on Google's compute.
So Google becomes your
operations manager essentially.
There is also a version
called Cloud Run for Anthos
if you already have
a Kubernetes cluster,
and you want to take on
more of those operations
responsibilities.
So really Cloud Run is
a really unique product
in that it offers
two different ways
to run the product, depending
on what your needs are,
depending on whether
or not you want
to take over operational
responsibilities,
or if you want to hand
those over to Google.
And if you provide any
stateless container,
you can run it on
either platform.
JON FAUST: Can you tell us
why Cloud Run is so important?
And I know that you
mentioned that there are
two different flavors of it.
Can you tell us a
little bit of why
Cloud Run is so important
to developers and a lot
of enterprise customers?
Yeah.
Of course.
So one of the pieces of feedback
we got with Google Cloud
Functions was that people
wanted to do Serverless,
but they wanted it
without the restrictions
of the environment.
So typically with Serverless
products, Cloud Functions,
Lambda, that kind of
thing, you have limitations
on what runtimes are supported.
Because it's essentially
providing a wrapper
around your code,
and you provide just
your function execution.
So there are specific
languages that are in use.
You usually can't install
anything in your environment.
If you want dependencies, you
have to do a lot of extra work,
especially if they're
native dependencies.
So what we decided
was, hey, how do we
make more things Serverless?
How do we make it if you have an
existing app, such as one that
does server side rendering,
like Python Flask,
or ASP.net, how can you
bring that to a Serverless
environment, and really not have
to rewrite your code entirely?
Use the same exact tools
that you're used to.
So that's why we
based our product
on standard OCI containers.
And essentially you
provide stateless.
Cause you can't depend on
state in between invocations.
The other thing that's
unique about the product
is that it will reactivate
existing instances.
So unlike functions as a service
products where you can only
have one instance per
execution, here you
can set a concurrency setting.
So it can be one,
which would match
the behavior on a functions
as a service platform.
Or you can set it to
something like 80,
which means that you get
to reuse those instances,
similar to how you would have
a traditional application.
So it allows you to
be more efficient
with your compute resources.
AJA HAMMERLY: So you
mentioned containers.
Do I have to be an expert in
containers to use this tool?
DONNA MALAYERI: No.
Which is great.
I can tell you,
I literally spent
an hour debugging an issue
in my Docker file once.
And I personally find
it kind of challenging
to use Docker files,
especially coming
from a Serverless environment.
Now, the cool thing is,
because OCI containers are
a standard format, there's a
lot of tools that will generate
a Docker container for you.
So there's Jiv for Java.
There's Ko for Go.
And then there's also
the CMCF build packs
project, which is done
by pivotal and Roku.
So essentially, you get
the really nice experience
that you get on a
platform like Roku,
where it looks at your
code, it figures out
what language you're using, and
it builds a container for you.
And when you use a
build pack, that's
exactly the experience you get.
So you don't even have to author
a Docker file if you're not
interested in doing that.
AJA HAMMERLY: Hm.
OK.
That sounds much,
much more approachable
than I was imagining.
So Cloud Run is based on
containers rather than
functions and the functions
as a service model
that Google Cloud Functions
and AWS Lambda use.
Can we still count
it as Serverless?
DONNA MALAYERI: Yeah.
That's a really good question.
Because when Lambda came out,
that was the first Serverless
product.
And people started
associating functions
as a service with Serverless.
In fact, people said
Serverless was only compute.
And it has to be, you
provide snippet of code.
And if you do anything else,
then that's not Serverless.
The thing is that
in the community,
the definition of
Serverless has evolved.
So people talk about
Serverless databases.
People will talk about something
called serviceful computing,
where you're using more
and more managed services,
rather than running
things yourself,
like if you use a machine
learning service, rather than
training your own model, or
running a machine learning
workload on VM.
So essentially, one way to
think about it when you're
running a container is that
you've taken on a little bit
more responsibility.
You are essentially deciding
what OS packages you want,
what base image you want, and
what runtime you want to use.
So that means that you have
to keep your Docker file
or whatever you're
using up to date.
So if there is a security
issue in your language runtime,
you are taking on
that responsibility.
So there's not
necessarily an option
that's the best for everyone.
It's really a matter
of trade offs.
If you need to install
custom packages,
if you have an existing
app that really doesn't
work in a functions as
a service environment,
then something like Cloud
Run is a really good fit.
If you want to provide
just snippets of code,
and have more of a
managed experience,
then you can use a product
like Google Cloud Functions.
The other thing is that you
can actually mix and match.
So we've put out an open source,
JavaScript Functions Framework.
And essentially
what that does is
it gives you that
same experience
that you have on Google
Cloud Functions, except you
can run it in a container now.
So you don't have to choose
upfront which version you want
to use if you want to have
a functions experience
or a container experience.
JON FAUST: Awesome.
You mentioned
there are sometimes
several trade offs to using it.
I'm curious, what are the
pros, the best feature
set that you can probably
give us about Cloud Run?
DONNA MALAYERI: So the
thing that's really unique
is the fact that you can
bring existing applications.
There is no other
product that offers
that in a Serverless model.
There's obviously a lot
of products for running it
in a serverful way.
But if you want
to run Serverless,
you typically have to
re-architect your application.
The other thing
that's really unique
is the fact that you
can reuse instances,
like I was mentioning.
So that means that you have
essentially a very similar
execution environment with
the efficiency that you have
with traditional
compute, except you
don't have to manage
the scale out yourself.
You don't have to
pay for instances
when they're not in use.
And you can scale to zero.
So really you should
think of it as bringing
all the benefits of
containers, and the flexibility
that containers provide, and
the open tooling that there
is for containers along with
the benefits of Serverless.
JON FAUST: Gotcha.
So for any developer
which is getting
started or considering
using Cloud Run,
how do you decide whether to
use the fully managed Cloud
Run, versus the one
that just runs on GKE?
DONNA MALAYERI: That's
a great question.
So typically what we
found with customers
is as soon as we describe
the two products,
they know immediately which
product they want to use.
Most customers, as
I said, want to use
the fully managed product.
Because they don't want
to have the overhead
of managing a
Kubernetes cluster,
even if they have the expertise.
And if Cloud Run fully
managed meets your needs,
then definitely
use that product.
Now, there are a lot of
customers, especially
large enterprises,
who have decided
to standardize on Kubernetes.
Or they have on prem
installations on Kubernetes
that they want to
move to the cloud.
And for these customers,
it's a lot more
effective to reuse
their existing cluster
and their existing tools.
And what these customers
are looking for
is an easier
developer experience
so that you don't have
to be a Kubernetes
expert as a developer in
order to deploy applications.
And typically, with these
Kubernetes clusters,
since you have to
pre-provision your capacity,
you end up having a spare
compute that's not used.
So Serverless is a great
fit for these applications,
because it allows
you to scale out
as your workload
gets more traffic
and then scale back down.
So really it's a more efficient
use of your existing Kubernetes
cluster.
One scenario, for
instance, that's
really resonated with
some customers is
disaster recovery, where
they have the workload that's
running, say, in an
existing Kubernetes cluster.
It's taking up some
amount of capacity.
But if that fails, they want
to failover to another cluster.
And maybe the cluster starts
out with a very small size.
And then they scale up.
But essentially, you can
minimize the amount of downtime
you have.
And it minimizes
the amount of spend
that you have to use for
some compute capacity
that you may never need.
JON FAUST: Just
as a follow up, I
know you mentioned that
most of your customers
seem to want to shift from
being on prem to fully managed.
But what about those that
want to stay on prem?
Is Cloud Run still a tool
that they can still use?
DONNA MALAYERI: Yes.
So Anthos gives you a lot
of those capabilities.
So there's a few
flavors of Anthos.
Anthos is Google's app
moderization platform.
It's not one product.
It's a suite of products.
And the idea is
that it's typically
geared towards enterprises.
But as an enterprise, you
have existing investments.
And you want to see how to
leverage those investments.
So if you're running
on premise, on VMware,
we have a version of
Cloud Run that runs there.
So it's a very
similar experience
to what you would get
on GKE on Kubernetes,
but you get to run it
on your own hardware.
So we basically
have a few levels.
We have the fully
managed version,
where you're running on
Google's internal compute.
It actually runs on Google
Borg, if you've heard of that.
And Google is basically
your ops team.
We're obviously going to
make some assumptions on how
you want your platform to run.
If those assumptions
don't make sense for you,
then you can run on
Kubernetes and take on
more responsibility.
But you still have a
more managed experience,
where you don't have to think
about the actual hardware
and then the apps.
Now, if that doesn't
work for you either,
and you already have a data
center on prem or somewhere
else, and you want to use
that existing investment,
then you can use Cloud Run
for Anthos deployed on VMWare.
So it's really up to you
which one you want to use.
And the API between all of
these versions is identical.
So if you change
your mind-- you're
using the fully managed
Cloud Run, for instance,
and then your company
says, hey, please,
just put that all on
the Kubernetes cluster,
or you're using the fully
managed for your dev mode,
you can easily move
across environments
without rewriting any code.
And your config actually
mostly will stay the same.
AJA HAMMERLY: So when we
talk about all the Cloud Run
and Serverless stuff,
KNative comes up.
Can you talk a little bit about
KNative and its relationship
to Cloud Run?
DONNA MALAYERI: Yes.
So KNative is the API that
Cloud Run is based on.
On the fully managed
version of Cloud Run,
we don't actually run
a Kubernetes cluster.
But we do have a
Kubernetes API server.
So the API that you use to
deploy your application,
regardless of whether you're
using the fully managed Cloud
Run or the version that runs
on GKE, is the KNative API.
And that's why we
have this portability
between our platforms, and even
portability to other vendors.
So at Google Cloud Next
in April in San Francisco,
we had a demo in
the keynote where
we deployed an application
on the fully managed version,
then the same
application on GKE.
And then we deployed that as
well on IBM's KNative offering.
So because it's all based
on KNative, it's portable.
And the version of the
service that we run on GKE
is essentially the OSS version
with some additional GKE
specific features added on top.
You can move to other vendors.
And you can even
change your mind
and say, hey, I don't
want to even deal
with Google's installation.
I want to do everything myself.
I want just raw KNative.
You can do that as well.
AJA HAMMERLY: So KNative
is the interaction
contract folks can rely on when
using the various Cloud Run
products.
DONNA MALAYERI: Exactly.
AJA HAMMERLY: Awesome.
So I know that there has
been some Twitter discussions
and changes around
KNative governments.
Can you tell us a little
more about what's going on,
and maybe why some of the
decisions that were made
were made?
DONNA MALAYERI: Yes.
Of course.
So when we started
the KNative project,
Google was the main contributor.
We were coming up
with all of the ideas,
starting all the working groups.
Google was running every
single working group.
And then as the product took
off, it was pretty amazing.
We started getting
more partners.
We got SAP, Red
Hat, Pivotal, IBM.
And all these companies were
really eager to contribute.
And so we widened the
steering committee
to include Pivotal,
Red Hat, and IBM.
And the feedback that we
heard from both our partners
on the steering committee, as
well as the community at large
was, hey, Google isn't the
only contributor anymore.
Now, Google is 60%
of the contribution.
Why don't we look at this again?
Why don't we broaden this base?
So what we've
announced recently,
with very positive reaction
from the community,
is that we're going
to move to a model
where, based on
vendor contributions
and participation, which
doesn't have to just include
code contributions-- it
could be other contributions,
like design documents,
running a working group.
We want to give people
seats based on that.
And our goal is to make
it so that Google doesn't
have 60% of ownership anymore.
It's not the 60% contribution.
Where we have more and more
vendors, more and more people
taking leadership
positions, and ending up
with more diversity in
KNative, which really
helps everybody
in the community,
both our partners who are
building products, folks
who are contributing to KNative,
or just directly using KNative.
So for Kubernetes,
for instance, I've
heard that Google
contributes about 25% now.
And, of course, when it
started, it was 100% Google.
So we'd like to get
to a model like that,
where we have a very open
model with the community.
And now, the
announcement that we
made for the steering committee
is really just the start.
Some people were like,
hey, this is really vague.
It was actually by
design to be vague,
because we didn't want to
make decisions on behalf
of the entire community.
So today, for instance, we
hosted an Ask Me Anything
for the steering committee
where people could just
ask questions and talk about
what was important to them
for governance.
So we plan to do this in the
open and talk about, well, now,
what's the algorithm
for deciding seats?
How do we say when
people can be appointed
to the technical
oversight committee?
Let's firm up the requirements
for being a working group
lead and recognize non
code contributions.
So the goal here
is to be very open
and to work together
as a community.
Our goal is not to have this
be a Google controlled project.
If that were the
case, it would've
been a lot easier to
just open source this
and throw it over the
wall, versus what we've
intended to do,
which is to build
an open and vibrant community.
JON FAUST: This community
has grown quite large,
it seems like.
And it's safe to
say that Serverless
is no longer just a fad.
So can you tell us
if Serverless is
going to be the future
of cloud computing?
DONNA MALAYERI: So this
is a great question.
My view is that Serverless is
the future of cloud computing.
It's going to take a
lot of time for people
to move legacy workloads.
My view is also that in 5
or 10 years, when Serverless
does become more
dominant, we'll actually
see different products.
We'll start seeing
products where
you can run stateful
containers, where
you can have more aspects
of your application work
in a Serverless manner.
Now, the thing that kind
of turns some people off
when they see a platform like
functions as a service is
they're like, hey, this
isn't flexible enough for me.
I have existing investments.
And a lot of these
platforms are geared
towards 100% new development.
And this is a fair point.
And I think that's where
technologies like Cloud Run
help, and especially
Cloud Run for Anthos that
runs on Kubernetes,
because this means that you
have existing applications.
You can leverage
those investments.
So I think that in the
next 5 to 10 years,
Serverless will become
the dominant matter.
It kind of will be the default
way of developing applications.
And more and more applications
will start taking a dependency.
We'll have better ideas of
how to deal with existing
applications and modernizing
them, and really getting
the benefits of the cloud.
When the cloud came
out, it was funny,
because there was all
this marketing message.
And the technology
didn't really catch up.
There was this idea of,
oh, infinite compute.
You just write your application.
It scales out to
all these machines.
The vendor does
everything for you.
And, of course, what they
gave us was essentially
virtualization over hardware.
Right?
In the very beginning,
it was the IT team's job
that got easier and not
the application developer.
And it's taken a
long time, but I
think we're getting to the
point where now application
developers are really
able to leverage
what the cloud provides.
And to the point where
they're deploying
cloud applications themselves.
And we're seeing
new tools come up,
like Serverless
framework, Pulumi,
that make it a lot easier
for application developers
to now take on some
operations responsibilities.
AJA HAMMERLY: So this is an
entirely silly question, Donna.
But this morning
a bunch of us were
sitting around talking
about the weirdest thing
that we've put in a cloud
container for Cloud Run.
Someone was talking
about Pascal.
Someone was talking about COBOL.
So what's the
weirdest thing you've
seen someone put in a container
and then run on Cloud Run?
DONNA MALAYERI: So
a couple of ones.
One that was really
funny and I just
didn't expect it
would actually work
was people took
Libra Office, which
is like a fork of Open Office.
[LAUGHTER]
Which is like a
16-year-old binary.
Right?
I mean, it's still being
actively developed.
But some of that code
in there is pretty old.
And at Cloud Next,
when we announced
Cloud Run, we're like,
hey, we're telling you
you can take
existing applications
and run them on Cloud Run.
Let's prove it.
And the container is huge.
It's over 1 GB.
It has all these
dependencies, all these fonts.
And you can take
that application.
And so we had a PDF converter.
The other one that
was interesting
was my co-worker
is really, really
into functional languages.
So he had an app.
This is Mike [? Helmek. ?] He
did a demo at Google Cloud Next
where he wrote an app in Elixir,
which I hadn't even heard of,
which is a functional
language similar to Erlang.
And he wrote a Hangouts
Chat integration using that.
So that really speaks to the
power of using containers.
Yeah.
You can run COBOL.
Good luck trying to run
COBOL on a functions
as a service platform.
That's not going to be fun.
And, of course,
you're using COBOL.
So that's not fun.
But if you have these
existing applications,
and maybe you don't want to
touch them because nobody
understands how they work
anymore-- this is very common--
you don't have to
rewrite your entire app
to make it Serverless.
And that's really the power
of what we've offered.
And that's why it's really
exciting to see the uptake.
AJA HAMMERLY: So what I'm
taking from this is, Cloud Run,
not just for
greenfield projects.
DONNA MALAYERI: Yes.
AJA HAMMERLY: This is a
totally valid solution
for getting some of
that nasty legacy code
that you have in the cloud,
running in a scalable way
so you're not paying extra when
it's not in use and all that.
Super cool.
DONNA MALAYERI: Exactly.
And sometimes Serverless
folks in the community
keep talking about
rewriting apps.
And that kind of frustrates me,
because you have an existing
app.
And it's not broken.
Why would you spend your energy
rewriting that, rather than
doing something that's going
to move your business forward?
Because your customers
aren't paying you
for your beautiful
cloud architecture.
Right?
They're paying you for, what
are you concretely providing?
And when Amazon
launched their code,
it was like this terrible
mess of Perl scripts.
Right?
Of course, they improved
that over the years.
But customers didn't care
that there was Perl scripts.
AJA HAMMERLY: Yeah.
I like the phrase, I don't care
what the gnomes in my computer
are doing, as long as they
return the right answer
consistently.
DONNA MALAYERI: Exactly.
AJA HAMMERLY: Yeah.
JON FAUST: So you
mentioned briefly before
that IT is just going
to get so much easier.
Does that mean that we
will see IT professionals
and departments starting
to wear new hats, or less
of a need to hire IT
professionals for applications
that scale automatically?
DONNA MALAYERI: So what I
think is that IT is still
super important.
What I've seen among
working with developers
who are adopting
Serverless applications
is that they are often
very operationally naive.
They have always
historically worked
in a model where they're
writing their app,
and they're throwing
it over the wall.
And there's some ops team
that is actually deploying it.
So application
developers are kind of
in the dark about best
practices that ops teams
have built for years and years.
And they've learned through
trial and error what works best
and what doesn't.
So in my discussions with
folks in the DevOps community,
and folks who are traditionally
coming from an ops background,
is that most of
them, the ones who
are interested in up
leveling their skills,
are really excited
about this change.
Because now with the cloud
becoming more of the forefront,
ops is becoming more
and more important.
And it's becoming
more democratized
in that regular developers are
learning how to do operations.
And they're learning what
it's like to be on call.
When I worked at Pulumi,
are writing deployments
in a repeatable manner.
And they aren't just clicking
around in the console
and creating services
that they can't reproduce,
and they can't redeploy, where
you actually have a format
that you can redeploy.
And what we discovered was that
made it so that a lot of folks
didn't need a dedicated
person to do ops.
Now, of course, to get bigger,
you need some ops folks.
But what's happening is that
developers are now learning.
And so now you have this nice
collaborative environment
between the dev
and the ops folks.
You no longer have
this model where
people are throwing things
over the wall, where they're
clueless about how something
will work in production,
where there's friction
between these two departments.
And the ops folks are
annoyed at the developers
for destabilizing the system.
The devs are pissed
off at the ops folks
for not letting them
deploy fast enough.
And now we're
getting into a model
where you're working together.
You're thinking as a
developer what this
means, what an outage means.
You're thinking
about the SRE skills.
Or you're working more
closely with your SREs.
So what I'm seeing is that for
organizations that are really
eager to learn what
the cloud can offer,
there's actually
a really, really
great organizational
transformation that's
happening.
JON FAUST: I did a really
quick Google search
while you were
answering that question,
because I haven't looked at job
postings in a really long time.
And I was curious to see if
there was going to be positions
for ops engineers.
And I just searched ops,
just as like a general term.
And sure enough,
Serverless came up.
And then eventually,
those postings
started switching to
Serverless engineers.
So I guess to kind of answer
my own question as well, I
did see now there's going to be
more of a shift towards hiring
Serverless
professionals, as well
as those who still work in ops.
DONNA MALAYERI: Yes.
And, in fact, that's
a really good point,
because one of the first
uses for AWS Lambda,
and still to this day,
was for operations tasks.
So it was things like a
virtual machine has started up
in this AWS account.
Does it have the
right permission?
Does it have firewalls set up?
And if not, tear down
that machine immediately.
So those were the kinds
of automation tasks
that were very, very
popular with AWS Lambda.
And I personally talked
to some ops folks
who were like, I didn't
know how to use Python.
I only wrote some bash scripts.
But this has been such a
useful way to automate my job.
So tools like Lambda
and Serverless
aren't just for developers.
They're for everybody.
AJA HAMMERLY: Yeah.
One of the talks
I gave this summer
was about how don't be
afraid of the Serverless.
And it lets ops folks
focus on the hard
and the interesting problems,
and make some of the tedium
and boredom, which our Azure
team here at Google calls toil,
go away.
And I think that is so
cool and so powerful.
DONNA MALAYERI: Absolutely.
AJA HAMMERLY: So I think we're
running a little short on time.
Is there anything that we missed
or that you want to mention?
DONNA MALAYERI: If the term
Serverless is scary to you,
or if you feel like it's
too hard of a cliff,
and you want to stay in
the safety of your existing
applications, you don't
need to be worried.
Don't be scared by
folks who are doing
really weird things
with AWS Lambda
and are the cutting edge.
Because you're always
going to see people
doing the cutting edge stuff.
I think Serverless has a lot
to offer existing applications.
And you don't need
to rewrite your code
to leverage these benefits.
AJA HAMMERLY: So
is there anywhere
that you're going
to be if people
who listen to the podcast
want to see you out
in the community?
DONNA MALAYERI: Yes.
So I'll be speaking at
Google Cloud Next in London.
And I did a keynote and
a talk at Serverless Conf
in New York City.
And those videos will
be available soon.
So I recommend checking
those out, as well as some
of the other speakers there.
There were some really
interesting talks there.
AJA HAMMERLY: And if folks
want to find you online,
are you on Twitter?
Is there a good place
for them to look you up?
DONNA MALAYERI: Yes.
I'm on Twitter @LindyDonna.
And I post about all kinds of
things, including cat photos.
AJA HAMMERLY: Ooh, cat photos.
[MEOW]
JON FAUST: Well, that's
going to wrap it up
for this episode of the podcast.
Donna, thank you for joining us.
It's been an absolute pleasure.
Aja as well.
And we really hope to hear
of all the great things
that Serverless is going to
be doing in the near future.
DONNA MALAYERI: Thank you.
AJA HAMMERLY: That was so cool.
Donna clarified a
whole bunch of stuff
that I hadn't quite
sorted out for myself.
So I'm really glad we
got to talk to her.
And her passion for that
area is so infectious.
But now it is time for
Question of the Week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
So Jon, I know you've been
digging into Open Match,
the open source
matchmaking for games
project that a bunch of folks
are working on right now.
Can you tell me a
little bit about where
I could learn how to write a
matchmaking function for Open
Match?
JON FAUST: Yeah.
Sure.
So as of today or yesterday,
the 0.8 release candidate
has been released.
So on that release candidate,
you will see a lot of notes
and getting started guides
on creating a matchmaking
function, setting up
the director, which
will allow you to connect
your players to servers,
as well as messing around
with your front end.
So the release candidate has a
lot of getting started guides.
So to answer your
question specifically
about how to write a matchmaking
function, what you're
going to do is, we have a small
template on what a matchmaking
function looks like.
You have to file a ticket.
And then you pretty
much submit a proposal.
And then once your
proposal is accepted,
you're returned a match.
And when you get
returned that match,
then the director will
connect you to your server.
And after you've written this
function using the template,
or maybe if you want
to play around it,
you can alter it
as you like, you
are going to build
a match make image.
And then when you
push that image,
then everything is
easy peasy after that.
You're going to push it to
your configured registry
that you have associated with
your Open Match image as well.
So hopefully that's
not too overwhelming.
And hopefully our
guides get you started.
And hopefully you
have some fun with it.
AJA HAMMERLY: And if folks
are running into trouble,
is there a way that they can
give y'all feedback on that?
JON FAUST: So you can reach
out to the Open Match Twitter.
We take a lot of
questions there.
You can ping me directly,
@SyntaxError1 on Twitter.
And you can also join our Open
Match community if you like.
I will post a link to our Slack.
And we're always looking
forward to having
new members, new
contributors, or just people
with general feedback.
AJA HAMMERLY: That
is so cool, Jon.
So are you going to be
anywhere anytime soon?
I think everyone's doing
a bit of travel cumin up.
JON FAUST: Yeah.
I have a bunch of
travel coming up.
I'm going to be at Anime NYC.
It's going to be pretty fun.
[CHIBI GIRL COOS]
Afterwards I'm going to
a wedding in Maryland.
All my friends
and family decided
to get married this year.
So a whole bunch of weddings,
a whole bunch of suits,
and a lot of ties.
And after that I'll
be going to KubeCon,
which should be
really fun, where
we're running the [INAUDIBLE]
and Open Match Workshop.
ROBOT VOICE: Nice.
Now, you're talking.
JON FAUST: And that'll
be from the 18th
until the 22nd I
believe in San Diego.
And to round things
up for my year,
I'll probably be messing
around and traveling
to Kirkland to meet with
the [INAUDIBLE] team
for Open Match.
AJA HAMMERLY: Wow.
That's a lot of travel.
So while you're at
KubeCon, I'm actually
going to be at GCP Next London
talking about Cloud Run.
I'm going to be moderating
a panel in the dev zone,
and also just hanging
out, work staffing booth,
checking out people.
I'll have stickers.
If you like dinosaur
stickers, come find me.
I'll give you a
dinosaur sticker.
[GROWLING]
And that is November
20th and the 21st
at the ExCel Center in London.
After that, I am unclear.
I thought I had plans.
And then they got confused.
So I will let everyone know on
my next episode of the podcast
where I'll be after that.
JON FAUST: That's awesome.
I wish I could go
to Next London.
I do enjoy going to
London quite a bit
and have some
really good friends
that are GDEs that are
probably attending as well.
So I'm very jealous.
AJA HAMMERLY: Yeah.
It should be a good time.
So I think that's all
we got for this week.
Thanks, y'all for listening.
JON FAUST: I just want
to thank our listeners
for tuning in another week.
And we'll look forward
to seeing you next week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]